hey guys i'm ryan right hey then
veronika success we're gonna watch a
special little video today called
singing my mama's song on my facebook I
posted about how I like really thank my
mom for last year
Veronica actually wrote a song for her
mom that's fantastic so I thought like
this would be a great video just to
watch together I don't know what it is I
don't know if it's a comedy video or not
we both love our moms so this is our way
of saying thank you by watching this
video yeah that's the most we can do for
you too anyway
mom's video together it's okay
everything's gonna be okay all right
I promise okay doing her song
well right here right here right now
that was really sweet
ah that makes me think about my mom a
lot it really does
my mom had a really - I mean it's kind
of talking about me too it wasn't too
long ago just a little over a year or my
mom lost both her husband and her mother
10 days apart
she's hands-down one of probably ya know
she's the strongest woman I've ever met
the strongest my whole life my dad has
been sick and so she's been the
breadwinner always worked always always
provided whenever I go through financial
struggles she's always there for me
she's the best she's not the most you
know I did a I don't if you ever saw
that video I didn't x-men trailer review
and she's not the most social person but
she's really cool I mean she grew up
reading comics as well she loves movie
she loves books she doesn't know this
yet but I actually wrote her a song and
she she hasn't heard it yet this was
just more inspiration for me to check it
out his mom is great she's really really
sweet and she got me a huge box of See's
Candies for Christmas and the Laura is
good - you're good you're a good mom - I
love my mom she's totally underrated I
know I that I won't truly understand and
appreciate her until I'm you know well
into my adult years I know that she's
gone through a lot with raising us and
you know dealing with issues with my dad
being a woman and loving a man it's not
easy
no I'm talking about us anyway I wasn't
talking about that was me joke about us
this is what we're talking about I know
but you you know me I started to get
emotional so like I sense of humours
so the defense mechanism sorry please
continue anyway
she she I love my mom too it's really
sweet inside at the same time because
she's she's clearly got something like
Alzheimer's yeah that's what I think -
yeah and just like the joy in his face
he's just used to it and he just loves
his mom and just goes with the flow and
plays her song hey I love how expressive
he is to her my grandma my dad sighs she
develop Alzheimer's as well you know
it's hard to communicate with someone
who has that it's really difficult and
it's specially difficult when you're on
the Emmy it's so hard for them but when
you're on the other side of it it's like
it hurts to have that to not be able to
properly just connect this guy is like
he doesn't let that interfere yeah you
know he's still gonna tell her how much
he loves her and expressed to her a lot
treat her with this constant joy you
know like it doesn't seem like he lets
whatever she's going through weigh him
down despite the uncertainties and and
confusion from her she she's still so
clearly and not in love romantically of
course but she adores her son
they're pretty adorable to watch
together and the folk song is dope
I love folk II yeah PT's I don't know if
you guys were able to hear every word
that was being spoken so there's gonna
be a link in the description box yeah so
you can check out the video yourself we
don't want to wait till Mother's Day so
we wanted to say thank you
mothers thanks mom and thank you to all
the moms if any moms watch this channel
my mom surprisingly watched these videos
but she never tells me yeah she'll be
like how salary house how does a listen
oh my you know who they are
she does care she does care her actions
definitely really show it anyway guys
thanks for telling us this video is out
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
like to do a lot of stuff and veronica
has a pretty much of its music channel
music and vlog channel which is locked
covers and she has a song tube that she
wrote
for her mom that you can check out it's
very humorous fun and cute check it out
we'll be continuing shoutouts again so
go to facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you say something
interesting and earn yourself a
shout-out earn it Ernie he got to work
hard hard say something interesting that
he can work off of if you want your
shout out to be funny and exciting